depuis la nuit des temps les rencontres
amoureuses suscite la curiosité de tous
comment draguer et comment rencontrer la
bonne personne des questions
universelles dont la télé s'est
rapidement emparée dans les années 80 ce
sont des émissions comme tournez manège
qui ont popularisé le genre est ce que
vous vous êtes quelqu'un de passionné ou
est-ce que vous êtes capable d'un amour
tranquille voire platonique
ah bah moi quand même anthony que oui
depuis la forme a évolué mais le fond
reste le même opération séduction au
bachelor en passant par qui veut épouser
mon fils mariée au premier regard ou
encore l'amour est dans le pré
les concepts se suivent et les couples
continuent de se former donc
[Musique]
je des couples dont certains tiennent
pour de bon à l'instar de pierre et
frédéric qui se sont rencontrés dans
l'amour est dans le pré en 2012 j'étais
content de passer ce moment avec toi et
qui sont aujourd'hui les hérauts parents
d'un petit garçon
même chose pour charline et vivien
couple rencontré l'an passé dans marié
au premier regard qui sont eux aussi
plus amoureux que jamais je pensais pas
que au bout de seulement 48 heures on
pourrait mais c'est moins lente mais
dans les émissions de dating l'alchimie
n'opère pas toujours bref tous les
couples ne sorte pas indemne de ces
émissions alors selon vous peut-on
trouver l'amour dans une émission de
dating nous a rejoint ex-candidate de
break le milieu des remercie marjolaine
ya toujours aussi magnifique et je
dirais la même chose de thierry thierry
olive bien sûr de l'amour est dans le
pré
savamment thierry oui très content de
voir que vous avez trouvé l'amour dans
l'amour est dans le pré vous mais oui ça
fait déjà huit ans de mariage dit pas
c'est vrai huit hommes mariage m
marjolaine vous vous étiez dans greg le
millionnaire alors là je vous dis
c'était en 2003 greg le millionnaire
l'émission rendez compte ça des faits
sensations on a retrouvé le pré
générique qui explique les missions vous
allez me dire si vous avez trouvé
l'amour grâce
voilà cette émission ou pas ou à
d'autres si on regarde c'est parti
grégory est un garçon simple il vit
grâce à des chantiers et des petits
boulots il va échanger sa vie modeste
contre une vie trépidante de multi
lignes d'un jour particulier
désormais riche il doit apprendre les
codes de son nouveau monde avant que
greg le millionnaire ne rencontrent ces
vingt prétendants parmi nous doit y
avoir certainement des retours
trouvera-t-il celle qui l'aimera pour
lui et non pour ses millions
[Musique]
c'est excitant et marjo elle est ce
qu'on peut trouver l'amour dans une
émission de dating bon à l'époque quand
on allait sur ce genre d'émission savais
pas du tout mon allez vous voulez faire
quoi vous faire remarquer voulais être
comédienne frost moi j'étais encore fait
renforcer sa tenue un gâteau florent et
quand j'ai passé le cut
j'ai même pas passé le casting en fait
on voit juste fait un entretien et
qu'angela lorente la production
d'émissions m en 10 minutes à m'a dit
c'est bon on te prends je n'ai même pas
vu de psychologues du tout je suis
partie 48 heures après un accord et avec
greg et il ya eu un petit quelque chose
à l'époque j'avais parce que je me
rappelle d'une nature rappelle quand il
était dur il faut utiliser quand même à
beaucoup à l'époque regarder je me
rappelle moi d'une vidéo il était dur
tous partis
balala
quand même
emotionnellement apprécié à ce qu'ils
sont amers
suite au rachat
ça que je suis là je suis sûr partout
je suis dur partout la halle
c'est durant ces dures dans tous les
sens du terme
rien amusé à l'époque et c'était drôle
et puis j'étais jeune j'ai vraiment
trouvé la mort à ce que gray que c'était
votre style à l'époque ou pas du tout
vous vouliez juste quand j'avais 23 ans
déjà donc ça faisait pas très longtemps
que
que je connaissais des sommes d'accord
normal oui si donc j'étais plus là pour
m'amuser
au départ je me suis laissé emporter
dans le jeu et voilà mais vous étiez
vous avez vous y avez cru bon accueil la
voie du toit en fait à la base sortie
d'une relation en fait d'une rupture
amoureuse avec qui j'étais enfin j'étais
avec quelqu'un depuis deux ans et en
fait à la base c'était vraiment plus
pour me changer les idées
c'était pas du tout pour entrer dans une
montre rassurant mais c'est un peu alors
quand même déjà au cas moi je le connais
c'est superbe
d'accord d'accord alors il ya jean
michel vous êtes le seul à dire non non
parce qu on y va toujours pour les
mauvaises raisons qu'on fait des
émissions de dating ces ou vraiment
parce qu'on est un chien donc façon
c'est pas une émission sim a changé dit
oui et non à quoi oui d'accord ok
d'accord là pour le coup je comprends et
98% des films font pas ça pour trouver
l'amour elle fonce à passer l on by de
briller d'être à la lumière de femmes à
télé d'être animatrice jusqu'à une chose
c'est qu'à l'époque en 2003 2004
on connaissait rien du rire de mode
éthique n'existait même pas aujourd'hui
le fait d'aller à la télé pour briller
ça n'existait pas non plus donc c'était
plus une aventure cirque on nous
appelait on disait voilà il ya une
histoire il ya il ya un concept vous
allez rencontrer quelqu'un de très
sympathique qu'est ce que vous voulez
vivre une aventure en voyage aux gens
sur le chômage cherté du nord la seule
mais bon pourquoi pas c'est bien
philippe lemettre gérer pour florence
était de l'acting quand même ça va me
propulser quand même un moment parce
qu'on n'était pas du tout dans cette
optique là à l'époque l'impact d'été
arrêté s'était pas on savait même pas en
aller retour n'était sur les émissions
savais même pas que ça allait avoir un
impact aussi alors je n'ai rien qu'à
trouver l'amour c'est le contre exemple
un c'est thierry au lit et oui thierry
olive comme quoi la septième saison de
l'amour est dans le pré
il a rencontré amis avec qui il s'est
marié depuis ça fait huit ans qu'il est
marié à dieu bénisse féroce
vous êtes le candidat le plus culte de
l'amour est dans le pré vous avez marqué
l'histoire de l'émission cas ça va être
formidable histoire et en plus grâce à
la réussite est vrai oui sont mariés
depuis huit ans issus tiff
regardez on à résumer votre parcours
l'annoncé membres tient à wissant
moi j'ai toujours vrai mais j'ai un
petit souci dans la santé c'est que dans
la fin de semaine prochaine c'est la fin
de la semaine
c'est pour ça que ce n'est même pas trop
à venir opération là où je suis va
mettre une prothèse en service après
vente avec toi c'est bien ça m'inquiète
c'est la jambe de gauche seydoux a
peut-être pas thierry hesse à l'abri
mais il a quand même il voit la passe et
dramé et ne serait ce pas une opération
qui se passe très bien c'est un grand
plaisir parce que je suis venu quand
même presque l'année d'après ou même de
la même année
supplantant avec jean louvet j'aurais
fait ça mais je vous ai pas l vous ai
jamais revus est un peu entre deux mais
vous n'êtes plus magnifique corps
cabaret vous savez quoi
en même temps pour l'opération de la
hanche fait une petite opération des
yeux également je pense oui
une bride et à deux mois oui pas de
problème c'est pas la couleur qui me
dérange c'est de retrouver un hacker qui
est prêt à prendre le mien et moi à
donner le mien envers elle
c'est formidable de te rencontrer quoi
mon souhait maintenant c'est de trouver
une femme déjà ça ne fait pas peur de
marcher dans la boue au point du tout
[Musique]
oui
ceux-ci rue
elle mérite est toujours amoureux ça
tient depuis huit ans donc tu remercies
démission quand même j'ai un marc coma
dans le flou demeure c'est parce qu'on
n'a jamais eu d'enfant ah oui au fait
des démarches auprès adopté mais ça
casse tête terrible aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il ya des gens des petits en
fonction la misère on pourrait beaucoup
les aider j'adore les enfants
ma femme a gardé sa fin un garde des
enfants les enfants alors une petite
fille a gardé une petite fille je suis
le papa mais de papa de la ferme
ils étaient là sont pas non plus voilà
c'est c'est noémie et bon défenseur puis
à nous et aussi et annie elle va bien et
est heureux voilà bellegarde les enfants
pascale les à l'euro avec vous bah je
pense qu'il faudra il demandait un jour
avec plaisir on l'invitera et
maintenance est devenu une star au non
je suis toujours un voltaire parce que
mais jamais à plus que je peux faire
vous regardez de l'amour est dans le pré
ou pas je regarde mes puis je regarde
aussi souvent jaloux petit nous et qui
fans de fort boyard
ah oui quand j'avais oublié la clé
restés bâtisse à plus de 590 en furie
toby flood je t'oublie la clé c'était
beau parce que si on m'avait dit je me
rappelle que tu t'es venu aussi hélas
donné le trophée du fou rire de l'année
exactement enfin quand j'ai même pas
tech à beaurains a appuyé à l'école mais
c'était plus baup et y avait aujourd'hui
quoique dans la cette année alors on a
là des deux coups vide juin à 110 un
bâtiment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais que tu sais que tu sais c'est
pas de chance mais elle tourne
on est là pour toi tu sais que tu adores
moi et me tiens oui je céderai je sais
bien mais moi je vous adore aussi les
battait et j'espère que vous me remettre
bien d' attaque plein de l'est pas et
prochaine j'en fais beaucoup de choses
et c'est rien ça sert un je te dis ça
c'est une opération qui se passe très
bien
là tu te papa donne à l'animateur tu
parles hanouna le docteur et d'innover
ou penser que oui on peut trouver
l'amour bah je pense que oui parce que
ici on a la preuve devant nous donc ce
sera compliqué manière non je pense
qu'en plus on peut suivre facilement
maintenant alors d'aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe dans leur vie réellement et on
voit qu'il y en a plein chez qui ça
marche donc pourquoi pas on va pas être
la moralité de tout ça je crois c'est
d'avoir la flamme
[Applaudissements]
on va on va on va reparler de la flamme
puisque fondements d une personne est
l'émission la plus culte de dating c'est
le bachelor c'était surréaliste entre
2003 et 2005 et à prester revenue sur
nt1 et dans le bas sauf pour ceux qui me
connaissent pas il doit donner une rose
à chaque prétendante qu'il souhaite
garder dans l' aventure sauf que parfois
avec le stress ça donne des situations
un petit peu gênante regarder poliana
[Musique]
c'est pas grave
moi j'ai dit brian a gêné j'ai cru que
j'allais partir en courant et j'ai faim
j'ai honte
le mc cord les avis et donc comme vous
les itunes a eu il ya des scènes dos à
mes années il ya des scènes limites qui
sont plus forts vous vous avez vous les
folles que nous c'est vrai j'ai vu des
trucs fous moi dans le bachelor
américain il fait une demande en mariage
aux cinq familles des cinq dernières
candidates et dans la même soirée il en
tech3 away sans que ça fou mais c'est
faux dans les séries de versailles
imessage le bachelor se repaître
castaldi il ya plein d'exemples même
dans le loft de loft 1 il ya encore deux
condamnés qu'ils sont ensemble qu'est ce
qu'on fait et tunisie voilà donc oui j'y
crois et souvent on se rend compte même
ceux qui sont pas faits pour ceux pour
qui les met en situation pour se
rencontrer
il rencontre d'autres personnes donc
mais juste un mot sur marc gène c'était
un phénomène même eu le droit elle a
fait le spin-off t elle est devenue l
c'est vrai c'était un vrai phénomène à
l'époque
est ce que ça vous manque la télé marche
aux jeunes facois maintenant sept agents
immobiliers non j'ai ouvert mon agence
immobilière d'accord aujourd'hui je gère
une équipe de dix commerciaux dont m 15
c'est pas facile tous les jours pendant
le coït donc là que vides et du coup
c'est pas simple mais mais bon
mais ça vous manque la télé tout ça est
ce que vous avez connu à la fraîche suis
là non on manque un peu d un petit peu
un petit peu parce que ça a été pendant
dix ans mon univers ouais donc c'était
très sympa moi j'ai adoré tous les
expériences que j'ai vécues elle était
géniale y avait des hauts et des bas
comme dans tout une image très difficile
à nettoyer
comme dans tous mes mais je crache pas
dans la soupe j'ai vraiment des les gens
vous reconnaissent encore ou pas ouais
vraiment quand vous fait visiter un
appareil même si pas marjolet un message
aux réalisations
je connais ce bas et non mais si oui et
alors les éditions vous reconnaissent
aussi ils n'en reviennent toujours voire
à la faire en quoi il ya encore cette
année mais tous les ans de façon à way
qui va les voir la fin ainsi vous savez
j'ai toujours invité ben là je vais
toujours par un espace diabète là bas
surtout la maladie du diabète
[Musique]
percussions c'est vrai on coupe on
couple aimant maintenant avec je sais
pas surnommé ce important
je sais bien c'est ridicule en sera
sujet c'est vrai que je suis peut-être
de pézan mecili présent que j'adore tout
découvrir la lors les sillons le
paraguay gens placés ou jean reno et
bien j'ai connu tous les pharmaciens les
lauzes officines de france c'est trop
beau
à deux minutes qui met les mains les
épices cela dit si tu es malade du
diabète
demain matin directement à 8h accord aux
pharmaciens il faut ce traité weezy
complément nous voyons
mais il faut que les membres parce que
on est mou et oui les coupes le pamen
promenez vous d'accord comme ça ils les
coupes
bah ça c'est un fait qui pioche à la cua
wayne - puis après si c'est pas si ça va
encore beaucoup plus haut combien
combien de gens qui sont pris dans le
diabète non mais tu as raison c'est de
lancer un appel
alors il ya une autre émission dont on
voulait c'est bien sur l'île de la
tentation
c'était sûr question
arrivé en coupe et on les tester pour
savoir s'ils repartaient en couple pas y
avait une scène mythique à chaque fois
que vous voyez que il y avait le
présentateur qui arrivait tu voyais ta
meuf en train de se défouler le gars il
arrivait avec un ipod un ipad était donc
là il ya ça bof il ya ça mais qu'au
tournoi était épuisé - kevin qu'avez
vous vu qu'avec
[Rires]
le champion du ghana
simplement vu ma base en train de se
frotter avec tous les mac de l'île d'à
côté mais c'est pas non plus n'y a pas
non plus pas non plus en faire un
fromage
on a diarra qui va venir nous rejoindre
pour happer de diana et brandon l'île de
la tentation
on a vu beaucoup de scènes hot monde a
également voulu beaucoup de scènes dans
boy dans l'île de la tentation
c'était quand même de ce concept c'est
un peu de [ __ ] le bordel dans les
mains ou encore baisser clairement ça
veut dire qu'il devrait officiellement
vérifier la solidité la bible of la
solidité des langues naviguer
tranquillement sur une plaque
on se moque car il dans the doc est donc
elle vit ça arrive ça est tranquille
maintenant tu es dégueulasse et en mal
on t'a 15,9 qui arrive sur un zodiac
quels sont ces cas que des bombasses et
elle te voyais ltte bois noir ne va pas
se voir brad pitt
tu vas sur l'île tient pas deux heures
faut arrêter mais brawn et je le mets là
bas frères 2 avril et ouais ok bonita en
fait c'est vrai trône et pourquoi tu
aurais pas tenus toi non merci
[Rires]
sous le choc des images
brandon enfreint toutes les règles de
l'émission et s'échappe ou rejoignent
palmetto le site des femmes hors de lui
brandon c'est armé d'un bâton et devient
totalement incontrôlable on ne dresse
relayant périence j'entends ma femme qui
vous a rejoint la décaler ou ans et non
merci des cherry à siliana merci diana
d'être là comment ça va ça va vous
n'avez pas changé à merci alors vous la
télé les émissions de dating ça a cassé
votre coupe ça moi ça a cassé mon cou
m'ont coupé qu'elle vient un peu brisé
au départ parce que pour aller sur l'île
de la tentation rien faut quand même se
dire bon vieux bras ballants on sait que
son couple tiendrait sur l'hydratation
castaldi non jonathan coad à ce que vous
pensez que le tien et évidemment la
sortie arrêtée place le voit il a défilé
à la maison mais pas il va tenir famille
c'est sur wii
ils sont pas des souris de zodiac
cheveux courts à la nage vers un boulet
retrouver one year
merci toujours le sens de la formule
c'est fou c'est beau kelly non mais vous
est ce que vous y croyez ce que vous
voulez pour être tentatrice elle a oui
mais vous pourriez tentacules jean
michel aulas
alors déjà n'a donc vous étiez amoureuse
de brandon très amoureuse de brenda ça
faisait quatre ans qu'on était ensemble
ouais quand même
il n'était pas très fidèle j'avais des
doutes mais bon je n'avais pas encore
choper avec quand il est allé faire un
petit doute et surtout que la veille de
l'émission personne le sait mais je l'
ai pris en flag
non ça arrive à l'émission j'étais
déchaîné je me suis dit je vais me
venger
et vous vous avez pq je me suis vengé
rue j'ai pris un petit home sont pas
trop mal d'accord oui un petit agenda
alors je n'aime pas ça c'est sûr et eux
abandonnent il était très énervé
ben salman vous l'avez revenus que vous
êtes resté pote a pris aux produits on
est resté potes mais on s'est séparés
ouais c'est ma raison me paraissait
quelqu'un qu'eric et séducteur parce que
du coup on est déstabilisé on devient
jaloux pour rien donc volonté d'avoir
fait cette émission financièrement non
parce que ça m'a apporté beaucoup
derrière on va pas se cacher mais
médiatiquement
sentimentalement bah ça a été dit de la
décision pour moi ça s'est arrêté puis
je suis passé à autre chose
aujourd'hui je suis très heureuse vous
êtes vous êtes avec quelqu'un de chez
les cavs fan ça fait huit ans qu'on est
ensemble et maintenant c'est moi qui
suis fan de lui quoi c'est vrai que
c'est un mec qui était fan de vous qui
me suivaient dans une émission qui
s'appelait révélation il m'a suivi
pendant le reportage
oui et on est resté à discuter ça fait
huit ans aujourd'hui ça vous sort très
bien et maintenant c'est marrant
les jeunes à dire du pénis non mais
vraiment c'est tout alors essayé de
chercher l'amour dans les émissions des
tic est ce que vous rappelez dhabi là on
l'a connu une aura dans l'amour est
aveugle
c'était dans l'amour est aveugle je
passe vous rappeler cette émission télé
sur tf1
comme l'indiquent le nom 6 à 8 personnes
qui ne s'étaient jamais rencontrés vont
apprendre à se connaître dans le noir
jusqu'à sélectionner la bonne personne
mais la découvrir à la lumière regardez
c'est l'émission qui a révélé la plus
grande star de téléréalité nabila
c'était sa première télé regarde c'est
la femme idéale celle dont tous les
hommes rêvent je m'appelle nabila j'ai
19 ans je suis étudiante en langues
pensent être une fille assez joli c'est
l'amour
moi c'est curtis d'accord enchanté naji
là bon je me dis que ce que la nature
m'a donné donc avec des plaies pas quoi
encore je suis quelqu'un vraiment de
rigolote de simples qui a des valeurs
beaucoup de valeur donc voilà
[Applaudissements]
dans les émissions de dating ça c'était
nabila oui jean pascal chaumeil soir est
quelque chose dont je me souvienne
l'émission par le fait qu'ils se répéter
partout tout le temps
c'était la présentation d'armes le maire
faisait l'amour est il à vagues
une info un scoop quand elle a fait le
casting n'était pas majeur elle avait
menti ce journal via l'un des candidats
les plus emblématiques de l'émission
c'est mike mack qui n'a pas trop
confiance en lui en tout cas juste dans
son portrait regarde viol je m'appelle
mac
j'ai 39 ans et je suis dj je ne sais pas
facile maintenant est fier recherche
maintenant les beaux gosses sur la terre
rouge et un strabisme et gluck tout ça
je n'y a pas que le physique qui compte
soit dans le coeur aussi dans mon coeur
je recherche une personne qui me
correspond à ce que je veux c'est à dire
si c'est un ton j'en vois pas un agent
et un pack des pins je vais en profiter
a dont je veux montrer de touques est
possible en moi pour mon s'est réuni et
je sais que je pourrais quand même la
parole était libéré à l'époque parce
qu'aujourd'hui on met un temps dans une
émission comme un garçon qui dit moi je
ferai tout pour m'en sers et wana et si
c'est un ton j'en veux pas mal un tollé
sur les réseaux sociaux le site
c'est un tollé jamais sortie en couple
de cette émission ils se sont médiatisés
certains à l'unité si j'aurais bien et
sait rien n'est jamais sorti alors dans
la vraie vie
michael était très chaud faut le savoir
il est surtout très chaude autre
candidature que l'on vit bas elle est
pas hyper réciproquement gratuit est ce
que c'est juste un petit cadeau ah oui
ça fait cinq fois je me tirais japonais
je sais pas mais voici ont vacillé face
à murray
et bloquer non et si on faisait un jeu
de devinettes
ah bah c'est très simple devinette il a
trouvé ma bouche d'un noir il papa
machine est inquiet port moi j'ai pas
peur ça soit à part deux membres à cette
annonce et femmes qu'elles sont
certaines questions
la tête embrasse moi et canon ça me fait
bizarre c'est pour ça me permet pas la
prochaine fois c'est franchement john
une fête ça passe pas du tout pas dans
ses intrigues ou alors même je voulais
vous montrer une autre image parce que
diana nous dit qu'elle a un qui peut
regretter d'orphée démission non j'ai
pas dis pas mais bon voilà
financièrement non mais bon ça a quand
même briser votre couple et il ya plein
de gens qui allaient de ouf quand il
voyait les images de leur conjoint
normal franchement non mais franchement
c'est d'après ce que les gens oublient
ils étaient à 1 km était sur l'autre il
il disait non on va te pour ça ni
comment quoi regarder va regarder mais
c'est vrai que là c'est quand on sait
les enfants dans ma vie comme trop
mauvais
ce qu'elle te dis
[Musique]
et
ouais l'eau passait bien
[Applaudissements]
mais ça c'était alors qu'eux mêmes font
des conneries de leurs côtés les chiens
la même chose c'est ça qu'on voit qu'il
ya problème comme ça qu'on rigolait
kaufmann sagna julien baer qui nous a
rejoint gignac vous connaissez
maintenant à saramon julien julien l'ars
a fait plus de sept ans qui participe à
des téléréalités vous êtes aussi
populaire voilà que ben voilà comme
étant les plus grandes stars non mais
c'est vrai tout vous connais vous avez
péché une dizaine de candidates dans
voter les rails
non mais c'est vrai et depuis un an il
ya eu un tournant dans votre vie on a
retrouvé votre premier portrait en 2013
mais vous annonciez bien pas la couleur
vous étiez pas là pour poser du
carrelage j'habite saint-etienne je sais
pas si le joueur est barman la nuit je
suis quelqu'un de très sportive qui fait
très attention à mon physique et tous
les sports qui peut me muscler vacher
preneur la plupart des gens qui me
détestent en particulier les mails c'est
des jaloux parce que souvent c'est j'ai
couché avec son ex ça sert sa cousine ou
même sa mère pour certains
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'accord à la team on est sur une
vraie source d'inspiration n'est jamais
bon de tarente quand tu vois ça je viens
franchement ouais bon souvenir longtemps
et je devais trop inspiré besoin c'est
ça tu as changé depuis
ouais est complètement ça fait un an tu
amoureux que j'ai pris un gros virage
dans ma vie là-bas on verra s'il vous
plaît là s'il vous plaît le micro
d'isabelle merci parce qu'isabelle est
en train de raconter sa ville en
coulisses on était contents mais on la
connaît alors on a fait une compilation
de toutes vos aventures
regardez julien en fait il a fait comme
le bachelor mais en plusieurs étapes
quoi c'est d'être sûr d'être aussi
charmeur moi je suis d'abord la partie
des belles gentiment je pense que je
peux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et là et julien vous vous avez trouvé
l'amour grâce aux émissions de
télé-réalité
en fait c'est ça vous avez vous êtes
tombé amoureux d'ilona candidat c'est ça
l'année dernière au cours d'une aventure
qui s'appelle les princes de l'amour et
la cb depuis deux chiens romy romeo
voyage à bali
vous avez fait je me demande premier de
sa personne et ses magnifiques voix de
deux chiens ouais ouais c'est ça écoute
j'ai demandé sa main il ya deux semaines
dieu bénisse elle a dit oui à vous vous
ne regrettez pas vous avez hélas
vraiment vous avez consenti que c'est la
femme de votre vie ouais c'est des trucs
ça s'explique pas je sais s'il veut pas
dire c'est une magie un truc qui te
prends tu vois si c'est comme c'est fort
c'est comme vous avez tout de suite
senti citer votre la femme de votre vie
annie bama fois j'attendais déjà
quelques années mais la salle c'est un
tournant ça m'a changé la vie mais c'est
vrai peut-être content d'avoir fait ce
qu'elle aime faire mais moi je fais mon
petit truc
d'accord vous voyez j'ai jamais fait une
manifestation de mourir alors je mange
les produits de me taire
nous sommes à terme et les patates de
moteurs et la carotte et la salade y
arriver meilleur que ça c'est magique at
elle aujourd'hui vous savez j'ai vu
michel
autrefois quand il faisait un film avec
cette pâte et verre plat je me rappelle
j'étais gamin mais je me mets moi
j'adore le naturel mais ma question
c'est est-ce que je tourne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comme julien et julien fait plaisir de
voir comme ça merci ouais c'est clair
que sont invités au mariage
oui sûrement oui j'ai pas l'impression
d'en alors dont julien à toi tu es
amoureux tu vas te marier donc
magnifique je suis très dur ans et ça
gianna tu saurais qu'un fan depuis huit
ans elle est très amoureuse
marjolaine je crois que tu as quelqu'un
dans ta vie c'est dire donc c'est un
laissez-passer discrètes sont restées
discrètes apparemment et du compliqué et
e
mais oui j'ai oublié vous avez mis
d'expression ce cheval
[Rires]